wer war denn vorher schon der der größte
Player wer ist wer sind die Nationen die
in Afrika wirklich die dominante Rolle
spielen also ich denke China das kommt
ja auch in dem Beitrag sehr gut rüber
hat das wirklich geschafft in den
letzten ich sag mal 20 Jahren seinen
Einfluss auch sehr systematisch
auszubauen das einmal die
seidenstraßeninitiative wo man eben
versucht hat mit verschiedenen Ländern
Verbindung aufzubauen also wirklich
physische Verbindungen die man
Straßentransport Infrastruktur helfen
baut dann eben was im Rohstoffsektor ja
auch angesprochen wurde dass man Kredite
vergeben hat auch für den Abbau von
Rohstoffen in afrikanischen Ländern wo
ich chinesische Firmen auch aktiv sind
das sind wichtige Aspekte man hat
Stipendien vergeben für afrikanische
Fachkräfte die dann auch nach China
gehen also auch darüber genau Kredite
darüber schafft man ja Verbindung ist
einfach diese physische Begegnung aber
ein junger Student aus was will ich
Kamerun oder Kongo woher auch immer
in der heute zum Studium ins Ausland
geht dann zieht es den mittlerweile eher
nach Peking als Nachweise nicht
Frankfurt oder Aachen oder sonst wohin
naja es sieht den Halt dahin wo auch die
Möglichkeiten hat und ich meine das ist
schon etwas wo man viel auch von
chinesischer Seite Energie investiert
hat und zu sagen wir geben Stipendien
wir bringen die Leute dann quasi in Anti
chinesische Universitäten die lernen die
Sprache auch darüber schafft man ja
Beziehung und Verbindung vielleicht noch
ein Punkt es ist aber nicht nur China
was eine zentrale Rolle spielt wir haben
bisher gesehen Russland auch im
Sicherheitsbereich aber zum Beispiel was
häufig untergeht die Türkei ist ein
zentrale Akteur in vielen afrikanischen
Staaten geworden auch ein wichtiger und
nordafrikanische Staaten die im
Endeffekt auch ähm stärker nach Afrika
schielen und man beschreibt das da als
ähm the news for a also quasi so eine
Art neuer Wettlauf für Afrika der also
dieses Begriff der eigentlich aus der
Kolonialzeit kommt und lange sehr
negativ verhaftet wurde aber ich glaube
was man sieht und genau das zeigt diese
Aussage das afrikanische Staats- und
Regierungschefs sagen na dann gucken wir
mal wer von euch das beste Angebot mit
plötzlich müssen wir uns hetero bewerben
wie nehmen denn die Afrikaner die
afrikanischen Staaten wie nehmen die das
denn wahr also dieses plötzliche
Interesse plötzlich fliegen alle dahin
und und halten große Reden und machen
sozusagen das ganz große Fass auf
beschwören diese Freundschaft und
versuchen darauf hinzuweisen also wir
waren ja gar nicht so schlimm zu Zeiten
der Kolonialzeit und so weiter das wie
nehmen die das denn plötzlich war und
wie steht dazu dieses neue afrikanische
Selbstbewusstsein also ich persönlich
erlebe das zumindest in Tansania so dass
das Interesse beispielsweise an China ja
gar nicht so neu ist als Tansania
entstanden ist also das Verbindung von
Tanganjika und Sansibar da war China
damals noch Untersuchung live Minister
einer der ersten die das Land anerkannt
haben es gibt eine gewachsene politische
wirtschaftliche
und aber auch kulturelle Beziehung
zwischen Tansania und China das lief nur
alles unter dem Radar und ich glaube es
gab jetzt ein wake up call als man hier
in Europa gemerkt hat oh wir haben
Ukraine Konflikt und einige Länder in
Afrika Stimmen neutral oder gar dagegen
was ist da eigentlich los und jetzt
fängt man an dahin ist das Ganze zu
hinterfragen und diese Dynamik die sich
jetzt gerade ergeben ist natürlich
Europa meines immer achtens unter Druck
ich habe
mein Buch geschrieben schon ein bisschen
älter und ich glaube es war in diesem
Buch oder Sie haben sie in einem
Interview erzählt eine eine Szene ZDF
Traumschiff ja Florian Silbereisen als
Kapitän unterwegs in Afrika
und sagten wenn man sich diese Seele
anguckt dann versteht man den kompletten
Blick von Deutschland immer noch auf auf
diesen Kontinent warum ja also der
geschätzte Kollege Florian Silbereisen
kenn ich ja auch aus der Arbeit mit
meinen Band zusammen in seiner Show aber
es ist halt eben dass in dieser Sendung
wurde folgendes thematisiert eine
Passagierin viel einem e-mail-betrüger
zum Opfer Geld weg das Fahren so die
Erzählstränge der zweite Erzählstrang
war dass die Nichte von Kapitän Parker
also Florian Silbereisen sich verliebt
hatte unglücklich verliebt hatte in
einen Schwarzafrikaner der gemeinsame
Sache mit Wilderern machte und wer
rettete dann das Nashorn dann ein
schneidiger
stellvertretender Kapitän vom
Traumschiff und dann war noch der dritte
Erzählstrang ein ganzes Dorf in tiefer
Sorge weil die Dieselpumpe nicht
funktioniert und wer geht dahin ja da
kam ein Mitteleuropäer der mit einem
Schraubenschlüssel dieser Dieselpumpe
zum Laufen brachte und ganzes
dorfjubelte das ist als Plot das heißt
der weiße kommt mit dem
Schraubenschlüssel und repariert ist das
schwarze afrikanische Dorf das kann man
ja auch gerne als Kunstfreiheit stehen
lassen das Problem ist allerdings dass
diese Sendung über 6 Millionen Menschen
geguckt haben und das natürlich ein
Pferdebild vermittelt
korrigiert wird wenn man dann von Afrika
als chancenkontinent spricht dann ist
das ziemlich schwer auch viele
Mittelständler davon zu überzeugen dass
es dort professionell zu interessant ja
ich glaube gar nicht böse gemeint aber
halt immer noch altes Denken wenn man so
will wie wird in Deutschland dort
gesehen Frage an Sie beide wenn es um
die Frage geht weil der tut sich ja
gerade was spannendes ne es gibt ja
vielleicht reden wir auch gleich darüber
es gibt ja so eine neue
China Müdigkeit habe ich das Gefühl an
vielen Punkten sind steht ja häufig in
Diskussion auch im Fernsehen der
Eindruck also die Chinesen sind uns da
im Jahrzehnte Ente alt die machen das
Geschäft und wir kriegen da kein Fuß
mehr die Tür ich habe das Gefühl gerade
ist ein unglaublich guter Moment um
diesen Fuß in die Tür zu kriegen und die
Frage ist wo steht da Deutschland
einen guten Ruf dort ich glaube also
hängt sehr stark von den Länder bzw in
welches Land man geht also in Südafrika
sind viele da sind viele deutsche
Unternehmen Präsident da gibt's auch
eine sehr viel stärkere bezieh dann
würde ich sagen rein Metall übrigens ja
auch ein Metall genau
hier sehr interessant im ehemaligen
Entwicklungsminister der der erzählte
das Rheinmetall dort produziert um harte
deutsche Auflagen zu umgehen das heißt
dann kann man als deutsches Unternehmen
von Südafrika aus in Ruhe beliefern wenn
man möchte genau die produzierender mit
einem südafrikanischen Hersteller dennel
und das ist quasi so eine Art Joint
Venture und es gibt auch relativ
interessante Studien von
südafrikanischen zivilgesellschaftlichen
Organisationen die das aufgearbeitet
haben wohin im Endeffekt
Waffenlieferungen dann aus Südafrika
gegangen sind und die dann
beispielsweise auch im Leben Krieg
eingesetzt wurden oder in anderen also
das zeigen die zumindest in dieser
Studie also offiziell haben wir da ist
wieder unsere Doppelmoral die sie in
ihrem Buch ja auch immer beschreiben
offiziell haben wir nichts damit zu tun
wir liefern selbstverständlich keine
Waffen in denen aber über den Umweg
Südafrika dann eben doch
genau wie gesagt das ein gemeinsames
Projekt auch mit südafrikanischen Firmen
also ich finde es immer wichtig zu
betonen weil wir häufig über den
Kontinent auch so sprechen als hätten
afrikanischer Akteure keine eigene
Agenda auch das haben wir jetzt ja auch
noch mal deutlich gehört also die die
Staaten haben ja selber auch eine
Möglichkeit Einfluss zu nehmen auch
quasi zu entscheiden mit wem sie
arbeiten das gleiche gilt für Firmen und
sie haben auch Möglichkeiten Standards
zu setzen die umzusetzen und ich glaube
das ist so ein Punkt sie haben das ja
angesprochen dass man im Endeffekt ein
bisschen China müde ist ich glaube dass
das nehme ich schon auch so war weil
beispielsweise im Infrastruktur
also bei der Unterstützung von das
Aufbaus von Infrastrukturen in
chinesische Arbeiter da vor allem
unterwegs waren auch im Bergbau Sektor
das dann sich die Frage stellt wie viel
lokale Wertschöpfung gibt es eigentlich
also Profi profitieren eigentlich die
Staaten profitieren Sie nicht es gibt
aber auch gelungene Projekte also ich
glaube auch das muss man sagen
[Musik]
ganz konkret sprechen weil es total
interessant wird finde ich immer wenn
man ganz konkreter reingeht also was ist
für sie ein Beispiel und sie sagen das
haben die Chinesen echt clever
eingetütet ich denke an Kongo Kobalt
haben wir gerade darüber gesprochen so
wichtig für die batterieherstellung und
wenn man hört das 15 von 19 Minen in
chinesischer Hand sind versteht man wie
weit wir da zurücklegen ja das ist
glaube ich noch also man kann sich
Rohstoffabbau das muss man ganz kurz mal
sagen so vorstellen es gibt den Abbau
von Rohstoffen also das was man immer
eben auch sieht in diesen großen
Vorhaben dann gibt's die zweite Stufe
das ist die weiterarbeitung von
Rohstoffen in schmelzen und dann gibt's
die dritte Stufe das ist dann der
Zusammenbau zu bestimmten Produkten zu
verstehen ne
Rohstoffgewinnung das eine Raffinieren
was anderes genau
zum Beispiel in ihrem Handy sind 30
verschiedene Metalle man kann sich jetzt
vorstellen jedes dieser Metalle geht
einen eigenen Weg manche und die
Lagerstätten die sind einfach da wo sie
sind ja das gibt nicht jeden Rohstoff in
jedem Land China ist halt sehr früh da
reingegangen also die china hat Kredite
vergeben für chinesische zum Teil
Staatsunternehmen die da im Abbau aktiv
sind und hat aber und das wird häufig
übersehen diese Schmelz und Raffinade
Industrie in China selber aufgebaut wir
haben Beispiele bei seltenen Erden ist
die EU fast zu 100% abhängig von
Importen aus China bei anderen
Rohstoffen liegen die Abhängigkeiten zum
Teil bei zwischen 60 und 80%, das sind
ja alles Dinge die wir auch für die
Produktion von Autos brauchen und das
ist glaube ich der Punkt dass man diese
Verbindung geschaffen hat das heißt man
baut quasi zum Teil mit chinesischen
Unternehmen Afrika ab ja hat die
Transportinfrastruktur nach China
ausgebaut arbeitet das in China weiter
und schafft das dann weiter nach Europa
formulieren ja genau und das ist glaube
ich die industrielle macht auch die also
durch die Industrie also durch quasi
eine wirklich
systematische Industriepolitik die China
da geschaffen hat die er im Endeffekt
auch Abhängigkeiten für uns mit sich
bringt
noch eine andere Zahl dazu von
136 Fabriken für Batterien für
Elektroautos die sind weder schon gibt
oder den Planungen sind besser also
Salzgitter offensichtlich tiefer VW Giga
Factory auch mit dabei von 136 dieser
Fabriken stehen 100 eine in China ja
aber das gibt auch einen Grund warum das
so ist ich wir sind immer so verwundert
wirklich
auf der Zunge lassen aber es gibt
tatsächlich auch einen Grund warum das
so ist ich meine wenn man sich die
Außenpolitik die Wirtschaftspolitik
China sich mal anschaut das Stichwort
Seidenstraße 4 schon die Seidenstraßen
Strategie zieht ja bis 2049 das wird
dann der hundertste geburtstag Tag von
der Revolution Maus sein so lange planen
die Chinesen ich habe hier so immer das
Gefühl dass von Legislaturperiode zu
Legislaturperiode bei uns in der CDU sie
wissen wie es läuft genau und insofern
natürlich aber insofern haben wir dann
ein ganz großes Problem und ein noch
größeres Problem meines Erachtens ist
das China eine
interessenslogik verfolgt und
Deutschland eher an einer
wertebasierte hilfslogik mehr oder
weniger die ganze Strategie ausrichtet
und genau da wie beispielsweise jetzt
Frankreich auch weg davon weil sie
merken dass sie da nicht weiterkommen
und noch klarer äußern dass die Staaten
in Afrika sie wollen nicht Partner
analysiert und bevormundet werden
sondern sie wollen eine Begegnung die
diese diese diese Ausdruck ist ja echt
schon irgendwie inflationär Begegnung
auf Augenhöhe aber sie wollen
tatsächlich dass ihre Interessen gesehen
werden und das findet leider viel zu
wenig statt also das konkretes Beispiel
feministische Außenpolitik
inhaltlich bin ich da Chor sind viele
Menschen da Chor aber wenn man jetzt
einen Diplomaten mal dabei zusieht wir
einem Außenminister Afrikas erklärt was
für ministische Außenpolitik ist dann
ist das schon relativ schwer das zu
vermitteln ich würde da kurz
widersprechen weil die südafrikanische
Regierung das ist ja gar nicht so
bekannt schon vor einigen Jahren das
Konzept feministische Außenpolitik
tatsächlich selber propagiert hat dass
und die haben das zum Beispiel als
Südafrika war gemeinsam mit Deutschland
damals nicht ständiges Mitglied im
Sicherheitsrat der UN da war es auch so
der Afrika das genau dieses Konzept da
verfolgt hat ich verstehe den Punkt ich
meine es gibt ja viel Kritik an diesem
Wedding aber ich glaube dass das was
hier häufig so negativ also gerade
dieser term dieser Begriff so
wahrgenommen wird in manchen Ländern gar
nicht so negativ ankommen also
die Frage ist doch wenn wir jetzt gerade
eben über China über Russland und über
die EU sprechen ja dann finde ich kann
man bei einer Präsentation der
zukünftigen Strategie des
entwicklungshilfeministeriums oder
Außenministeriums sich an so einem
Terminus verweisen was aber eben nicht
stattfindet ist beispielsweise wir gehen
wir mit der neu geschaffenen
Freihandelszone in Afrika eigentlich um
was für Antworten haben wir denn
eigentlich also Europa da drauf und das
ist etwas was gerade beim afrikanischen
counterpart viel für viel Irritationen
wir reden gleich darüber was so in den
einzelnen Ländern auch passiert und das
sollten wir auch zügig machen weil sonst
läuft uns die Zeit davon und es ist viel
zu spannend um das zu verschenken ich
will nur auf eine Sache hinaus ich
glaube was hat chiallo meint gibt sehr
gut wieder was ich neulich von einem ich
glaube einem kenianischer Student warst
gelesen habe der sagte weißt du ihr
Europäer ihr kommt immer mit eurer Moral
ihr exportal aber ich bin interessiert
daran dass der Strom 24 Stunden am Tag
fließt wenn ich ein kleines Unternehmen
Gründe und ich brauche einen günstigen
Kredit und beides geben mir die Chinesen
und das ist so das Gefühl das glaube ich
bei vielen Afrikanern
aber es geht ja noch weiter wir haben ja
seit der Digitalisierung in Afrika ein
völlig neu geschaffenen Marktplatz es
entstehen beispielsweise Start-ups wie
jobante die den Verkehr also
Güterverkehr Regeln also so eine Art
Paketdienst ja wo diejenigen die Pakete
versenden wollen und diejenige die sich
anbieten zu Fuß mit dem Moped mit den
LKWs die Paket Pakete zu verschiffen
oder zu transportieren miteinander
verbunden werden diese Erzählungen
finden hier überhaupt gar nicht statt
das kann man ausweiten auch in
kulturelle Bereiche gibt auch diesen
diesen Bezahldienst ne ja ein besser
beispielsweise aus Kenia was wirklich
eine gesamte globale erfolgsstoffe
globale Erfolgsstory die findet sogar in
Afghanistan hat die Regierung das als
Zahlungsmittel für ihre Beamten
übernommen
die Idee ist einfach dabei dass man die
Möglichkeit hat über das Mobilfunk Geld
zu transferieren also ich komme
ja man braucht keine Bank ist viel zu
man muss man braucht eine Station man
muss Leute beschäftigen hier läuft das
einfach so dass man geldtransferiert und
die Leute auch in den gegensten
entlegensten Gegenden haben die
Möglichkeit einen Kiosk was ein
Vertragspartner ist dorthin zu gehen
Geld abzuholen oder man hat die
Möglichkeit wenn das Geld auf dem Handy
drauf ist auch die Versicherung oder
aber auch Stromrechnungen zu bezahlen
also es hat wirklich entlegene Gebiete
wieder in den Finanzmarkt reingeholt
Menschen die Möglichkeit gegeben für
interessant Teilhabe zu leben und diese
Geschichten werden leider viel zu wenig
erzählt weil man durch diese machtlogik
die jetzt ausgelöst wurde durch den
Ukraine Konflikt ähm Afrika als eine
Stätte sieht wo man jetzt sich fragt wo
können wir mit wem ich auf Afrika hören
und auf die Leute die vor Ort sind die
haben für ihre eigenen Probleme aus
meiner Sicht ist über sozusagen das was
da passiert und wie spannend das ist
reden wir gleich noch mal diese Afrika
die sich China Müdigkeit Frau Müller ich
fand's interessant wer im letzten
Wahlkampf in Kenia William Router der
dort Präsident geworden ist wurde unter
anderem mit dem Versprechen Präsident
ich mache mal sozusagen die chinesischen
Geschäfte öffentlich da geht es um eine
Eisenbahnstrecke von
Mombasa nach Nairobi 3,6
unfassbar viel Geld sehr gut gehütetes
Geheimnis keiner kannte die Höhe des
Kredits keiner wusste was die
Konditionen sind und als er das dann mal
öffentlich gemacht hat wurde noch viel
mehr klar da wurde auch klar dass
sozusagen die Chinesen sehr genau darauf
achten dass die gesamte
Wertschöpfungskette von Chinesen
abgegriffen wird
heißt die Arbeiter das Know-how die
Materialien die man braucht im Grunde
eine riesiger Kredit zu ziemlich
seltsamen Konditionen sehr teuer und
gleichzeitig hat Afrika eigentlich
nichts davon außer irgendwann mal eine
Eisenbahnstrecke die afrikanische
Arbeiter zum Beispiel hat nicht
furchtbar viel davon ich taucht da so
eine neue Müdigkeit auf so einen so ein
Gefühl wer weiß ob das so super
Geschäftspartner für uns sind oder oder
merken die Leute Mensch da haben wir
eigentlich gar nichts von lass uns doch
mal gucken ob es noch andere Partner
gibt ja ich glaube das ist eine
allgemeine Haltung die sich nicht nur
auf China bezieht also ich glaube man
muss auch ein bisschen aufpassen es
klingt dann manchmal so als würde bei
China alles ganz schlecht laufen und bei
allen anderen europäischen Partner total
super aber nur eine Situation die es so
gibt in Afrika jetzt speziell man könnte
auch sagen in Sahel gibt's auch
sicherlich eine Frankreich Müdigkeit
aber genau wenn wir das mal so
festhalten ich glaube der Punkt ja der
Punkt ist halt ähm das ist wirklich
wichtig ist und in das hat sich
verändert über diese
wertschöpfungsfragen mehr zu reden also
Wertschöpfung wie sie sagen Mannschaft
Arbeitsplätze Mannschaft
Ausbildungsplätze also die ganze Frage
von
professioneller Weiterentwicklung auch
techn Energietransfer also das ist immer
ein ganz wichtiger Punkt jetzt auch in
den ganzen rohstoffpartnerschaften über
die jetzt gerade gesprochen wird weil
die EU ja auch afrikanischen Ländern
mehr rohstoffpartnerschaften anbietet
was viele afrikanische Staaten sagen und
das ist das finde ich sehr spannend wir
machen gerne mit euch
rohstoffpartnerschaften aber ihr
unterstützt uns schmelzen vor Ort zu
bauen also wir wollen das nicht auch das
ist nämlich auch der zweite Punkt wir
wollen auch nicht nur abhängig sein von
China mit Blick auf unsere Exporte wenn
es eine Energiekrise die china hat wenn
die ihre Produktion trosseln dann gibt's
ja auch weniger Nachfrage das heißt man
will das lieber vor Ort machen und man
will zum Beispiel diese schmelzprozesse
vor Ort haben und da kann die EU
natürlich unterstützen und in dem
Kontext auch quasi zu dieser ich sag mal
Wertschöpfung vor Ort beitragen und
ausbildungsinitiativen finanzieren und
so weiter da gibt's sehr konkrete
Vorstellungen auch davon hat kürzlich
gesagt wir ver exportieren kein
unverarbeitetes Lithium mehr also wir
haben die haben halt ein riesiges
vorkommende aktuell ich glaube das
fünftgrößte der Welt
das ändert sich immer wenn man immer mal
wieder was neues entdeckt aber brauchen
wir für unsere Batterie genau das gilt
als einer der kritischen Rohstoffe also
die quasi knapp sind und die aber sehr
wichtig sind für Zukunftstechnologien
und sind bei gesagt nee das wollen wir
quasi erst weiterverarbeiten und dann
exportieren wir es die DLC also die
Demokratische Republik Kongo und Sambia
haben einen Abkommen unterschrieben wo
sie sagen sie wollen erste Teile der
Batterieproduktion gemeinsam bilateral
vor Ort produzieren ja das ist wirklich
was Neues weil das sind ganz konkrete
darüber gesprochen haben ihr könnt das
gerne haben aber dann finanziert auch
die Energieinfrastruktur weil das
vergisst man häufig dass das alles sehr
energieintensive Prozesse sind das heißt
man braucht eine Energieinfrastruktur
man braucht eine Transportinfrastruktur
und dann wird es halt interessant weil
dadurch einfach mehr Arbeitsplätze
entstehen ja man hat nicht nur den Abbau
da gibt es eigentlich gar nicht mehr
viele Arbeitsplätze die geschaffen
werden neu weil da viele viel
technisierungen stattgefunden hat man
hat auch den Transport der dann vor Ort
stattfindet die ganzen Zulieferbetriebe
das sind halt die interessanten
Kooperationen und da und da muss man
auch sagen ist die Uhr auch ein bisschen
aufgewacht das gibt diese global Gateway
Initiative das ist im Endeffekt das
europäische Konkurrenzmodell zur Seite
Straße Initiative und ich glaube aktuell
das ist so dass 150 Milliarden Euro also
wir wissen jetzt ungefähr auch wir
können mit diesen Zahlen ja mittlerweile
auch in Deutschland mehr anfangen 150
Milliarden Euro sollen quasi dann auch
in afrikanische Projekte gehen und da
ist gerade eine Diskussion drüber ob man
nicht auch im Rohstoffsektor genauso
solche Dinge wie finanziert weil sie
gerade dieses neue Selbstbewusstsein
ansprechen ich habe neulich eine Meldung
gelesen Tesla wollte glaube ich mit
Nigeria eine eine Partnerschaft
eingehen um dort auch Lithium abzubauen
und die haben einfach gesagt nein machen
wir nicht wollen wir nicht machen wir
selber ja nein hat aber auch seinerzeit
in Ostafrika der letzte Präsident Marco
fuli gesagt als ich Chinesen den größten
Hafen
in bergamojo bauen wollten und diese
hafnerte 10 Milliarden gekostet und
hätte natürlich und das sind die Planung
sind immer noch da so Länder wie wonder
Burundi und natürlich auch den Kongo
Stichwort auch die seltenen Erden und
all die Rohstoffe die da geliefert
werden können ähm in die Welt hinaus
getragen und ähm hätte 10 Milliarden
gekostet ähm Rückzahlung in 33 Jahren
die Chinesen wollten das für 99 Jahre
Niesen der Präsident hat gesagt nein das
werden wir so nicht machen und bis heute
sie ist man gemeinsam in Verhandlungen
um dieses große Projekt doch noch
umzusetzen das zeigt für mich auch dass
wir nichts alles zu Ende in Europa
denken müssen sondern sie afrikanischen
Staaten auch die einzelnen Verantwortung
übernehmen wollen auch entsprechen
wir sprachen gerade über dieses kleine
Fenster dass ich da gerade aufmachen
gibt so ein paar Meldungen die wirklich
interessant sind also mit Blick auf
diese chinesischen Kredite zum Beispiel
gibt ja viele afrikanische Staaten in
dem nach meinem Empfinden das Gefühl
vorherrscht die würden uns wirklich den
Saft ab wir können das nicht mehr
bezahlen china hat glaube ich eine
Billion Dollar us an Schwellenländern
150 Schwellenländer an Krediten gewährt
sind Normen viel Geld haben mittlerweile
eigene Probleme zu Hause die chinesische
Wirtschaft läuft nicht mehr so gedacht
es gab Ende Dezember sehr interessant
Gabi bekannt Weltraumbahnhof genau dass
sie dass sie die Schulden an Peking
nicht mehr länger zurückzahlen können
ist eine wichtige Nachricht weil der
einzige afrikanische die einzige
afrikanische Militärbasis ist
chinesische Basis ist in schibuti in
Sichtweite zu einer amerikanischen
Militärbasis was bedeutet das dann die
Meldung aus Uganda zum Beispiel Uganda
gibt es glaube ich auch ein großes
Eisenbahnprojekt
wollen die auch nicht mehr mit den
Chinesen machen sind jetzt die Türken
eingestiegen das was sie vorhin gerade
sagen die Türkei wird dort ein wichtiger
Player
Sambia zum Beispiel hat sich wehren
müssen sagte pass auf nee wir können
unsere Kredit an China noch bezahlen die
Meldung dass der Flughafen in lusackern
der Hauptstadt dass der jetzt an die
Chinesen geht das ist nur ein Gerücht
aber man merkt der brodelt es an vielen
Ecken und Enden das heißt was passiert
da gerade ich glaube insgesamt und das
wurde ja vorhin schon angesprochen es
ist halt sehr spannend dass der
afrikanische Kontinent sehr viel stärker
auch gemeinsam definiert was man
eigentlich will also die afrikanische
Freihandelszone finde ich ist einfach
ein sehr sehr interessantes Beispiel
wird auch sehr wenig noch beachtet in
Deutschland ja und das war auch sehr
überraschend während der corona-pandemie
oder als die Pandemie anfing wurde ja
vielen afrikanischen Staaten auch immer
deutlich wie abhängig sind es gab keine
Produktion medizinischer
Schutzausrüstung auf dem afrikanischen
Kontinent ja und die EU hat gesagt wir
machen ein Exportstopp von medizinischer
Schutzausrüstung das heißt viele Länder
waren einfach komplett aufgeschmissen
ich bin auch dann später weil ich in
Südafrika und das war einfach wahnsinnig
teuer Masken zu kaufen das ist ja auch
der Punkt wenn man dann wenig hat sind
viele Dinge auch einfach sehr viel
teurer man kriegt das kann sich dann
kaum jemand auch leisten natürlich und
das hat auch noch mal so ein Push
gegeben für diese Idee eine
afrikanischen Freihandelszone die schon
lange unter Diskussion war die haben
jetzt quasi in Ghana ihr Sekretariat das
ist ein sehr junges sehr aktives Team
die jetzt gerade überlegen wie kann man
einerseits orientiert am EU-Modell
natürlich ja wie kann man den Freihandel
innerhalb Afrikas Stärken wie kann man
gemeinsam quasi grenzüberschreitende
Projekte machen die Freizügigkeit auf
dem Kontinent spielt natürlich auch eine
wichtige Rolle dass er möglichen in
welchen Bereichen ist wirtschaftliche
Entwicklung möglich und ich glaube da
man will auch gar nicht immer sagen da
kommen die eher die Chinesen die kommt
die Türkei oder die Inder oder wie auch
immer mit einem Angebot sondern erstmal
definieren was will man eigentlich
selber und wie schafft man selber auch
eine Art von Versorgungssicherheit weil
darum geht es ja ich meine wir reden
viel über europäische
Versorgungssicherheit aber für
afrikanische Staaten es ist ja genauso
wichtig und das finde ich eine sehr
spannende Entwicklung die dauern wird
weil das ist natürlich ein großes
Unterfangen
deswegen bin ich vielleicht auch nicht
immer ganz so kritisch was ich meine die
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit hat sich auch
ein bisschen gewandelt ne weil die EU
Unterstützung zum Beispiel das
Sekretariat finanziell ich glaube das
sind einfach wichtige Prozesse um quasi
afrikanische Institutionen auch zu
stärken so dass man dort auch selber
mehr in der Lage ist solche Dinge
umzusetzen ja hallo ich persönlich halte
nach wie vor die Entwicklungspolitik wie
sie jetzt läuft und das hat ja auch
immer ganz klar gesagt diese hilfslogik
die muss eine investitionslogik reichen
müssen
jetzt schon zum zweiten Mal macron
zitieren ich glaube wir haben diesen
kurzen ja den entscheidenden haben wir
hier okay lass uns einmal kurz reinhören
und dann reden wir mal darüber was das
bedeutet aber sehr interessant ihr müsst
doch schon mal anstrengen Freunde ja da
müssen die richtige Leute nach Afrika
fahren da muss man Spitzen Person
ein Musik darf ich die Smart solider
Konsistenz
fette
Auto okay ich hätte Problem
aber das ist genau die richtige Ansage
ich kann Ihnen mal ein Beispiel nennen
wenn der Entwicklungsminister oder die
entwicklungsministerin nach Afrika
fahren dann gehen sie schon spätestens
davon aus dass den Staatspräsidenten
genau dass sie den Staatspräsidenten
Außenminister mindestens und
Premierminister treffen wenn umgekehrt
ein afrikanischer Premierminister mal an
einem Freitag in Berlin aufschlägt da
kann er Glück haben dass ein Referats
ist eben das Probieren natürlich und das
ist eben dieser Form von Respekt das ist
wirklich so und Sie müssen auch etwas
was vielen afrikanischen Ländern wenn es
um Wertschätzung geht sauer aufschlägt
und ich würde mir echt wünschen dass man
deswegen spreche ich ja auch immer von
einer gesamten Strategie und zwar nicht
nur Entwicklungshilfe Ministerium
sondern das wie Frankreich jetzt macht
das das Chefsache erklären und sich
wirklich fragt was sind denn die
deutschen Interessen wenn man die
Chefchen schicken will dann muss man
sich vorher Gedanken darüber gemacht
haben was wollen wir eigentlich als
Deutschland und nicht welche Werte
wollen wir exportieren und das ist ja
man Anklagepunkt dass diese hilfslogik
sehr oft die Werte voranträgt aber die
Interessen Deutschlands überhaupt nicht
berücksichtigt werden meiner Meinung
aber ich glaube dass der Rahmen der
gesetzt werden müsste eben nicht
vollumfänglich über alle Bereiche hinweg
gedacht wird
natürlich auch nicht lesen
also diese
Afrika unterwegs doch doch doch also ich
habe oft gesagt wir haben da sozusagen
wir betrachten dieses Land als einen
Kontinent von Almosen Empfängern das
sind die aber nicht und das konnte man
eine Zeit lang wenn man durch Afrika
gereist ist konnte man das ja auch sehen
wenn man ins Hochland von Äthiopien
gefahren ist wenn die einen weißen
Menschen sehen dann ist sofort das
Gefühl der schenkt mir jetzt irgendwas
und ich fand das immer so würdelos ich
dachte immer das kannst doch nicht sein
richtig sondern oder die Leute die Leute
müssen doch
selbst Ermächtigung die müssen doch das
Gefühl haben ich ich kann selber aus
meinem Leben was machen die kann selber
was gestalten ich bin selber sowas in
der Lage und da gibt es so viel Talent
das aber keine Möglichkeit hat
ausgebildet zu werden und selber
wirklich auf eigenen Beinen zu stehen
genau ich meine grundsätzlich Interessen
und Werte können ja auch zusammen gehen
wir haben auch wertkonflikte und
manchmal haben wir auch
Interessenkonflikte also dass diese
Gegenüberstellung finde ich immer so ein
bisschen schwierig aber ich meine zwei
Beispiele
zum Beispiel wenn wir Rohstoffabbau
reden den nachhaltig und gut vor Ort zu
gestalten ist unser Interesse dass wir
sagen ja wir schaffen quasi
Versorgungssicherheit es ist auch ein
Wert und gleichzeitig zeigen sehr viele
Studien dass hier besser dieser Abbau
läuft um so nun unsere flüssiger geht
das dann auch sozusagen wir haben viele
Proteste gesehen
2012 gab es in Südafrika was ein sehr
relevanter platinlieferant ist Proteste
Platin genommen
Proteste nachdem es da im Bergbau Sektor
die Polizei streikt in der Minenarbeiter
erschossen hat das hat danach auch zu
Lieferengpässen global geführt ja und
das kann man sehr deutlich zeigen und
weil das Thema feministische das muss
kein genau zusammenkommen eigentlich und
man zeigt vor Ort ich meine man nennt
das im Bergbau Sektor im englischen
socialized to operate also quasi eine
soziale Lizenz zum
Arbeiten sozusagen oder oder operieren
dass wenn die Akzeptanz für solche
Großprojekte vor Ort da ist weil man die
Bevölkerung einbezieht weil die nicht
die negativen Umwelt und
sozialauswirkungen spüren dann sind
eigentlich alle zufriedener natürlich
ist es externalisiert man dann auch
nicht so viele Kosten das ist vielleicht
ein bisschen teurer aber im Endeffekt
langfristig ist es sicherer und stabiler
und alle haben was davon zweites
Beispiel weil dieses dieser Punkt
feministische Außenpolitik angesprochen
wurde ich war 2017 habe ich in im Niger
geforscht und hatte da die Gelegenheit
mit mit Frauen da vor Ort zu reden und
nieder ist ja immer so ein Beispiel weil
das die höchste Geburtenrate mit der
Welt hat und damals
genau genau
hatte ich mit einer Gruppe übrigens ne
genau extrem
Bildungsniveau also vor allem weil die
Frauen dort vor Ort also ich hatte mit
ein paar zivilgesellschaftlichen
Organisationen auf
Frauenrechtsorganisationen gesprochen
und das Problem ist dass quasi es gibt
keinen kaum Zug oder gab damals ich weiß
nicht genau wie es heute das aber wenig
Zugang zu Verhütungsmitteln das heißt
einige Frauen die hatten ihre Männer
haben in Nachbarstaaten gearbeitet die
haben die Männer gebeten dort
Verhütungsmittel mitzubringen weil sie
quasi im Staat selber dazu gar keinen
Zugang hatten und es gab wenig Angebote
zur Familienplanung das ist der Punkt ne
also dass man wirklich auch die
Möglichkeit hat und das finde ich es
genauso eine Form von empowerment wie
Sie es beschreiben also die Möglichkeit
hat sich zu überlegen wie viele Kinder
möchte ich denn eigentlich und diese
Voraussetzungen zu schaffen deswegen
glaube ich dass man sehr genau immer
hinschauen muss worum es eigentlich geht
und und ja nicht immer diesen Gegensatz
zwischen Interessen und Werten wo ich
aber zustimme ist dass es glaube ich
Deutschland und auch anderen
europäischen Staaten häufig schwer
gelingt zu sagen was wir wollen ähm ja
also wir verkaufen Dinge als Werte die
eigentlich aber auch Interessen sind und
das merkt man natürlich
ähm genauso im Rohstoffbereich ja wir
können natürlich sagen ja wir wollen
euch da gute Bedingungen Rohstoffsektor
schaffen oder wir wollen euch dabei
unterstützen wir machen genau wir machen
über
Kooperationen zwischen quasi Behörden
kann man zum Beispiel Ministerien dabei
unterstützen die Umsetzung von Standards
zu überwachen oder so aber wir sagen
nicht na ja wir wollen aber dafür
natürlich auch was und ich glaube das
habe ich ein paar Mal erlebt auch bei
afrikanischen Delegation dass sie sagen
ja was wollt ihr eigentlich von uns und
ich glaube da auch ehrlicher zu werden
weil das ist natürlich auch klar wir
sind ja nicht alle Freunde sondern sind
staatliche Interessen